okay thank you here we are with the
questions Ronin were you surprised that
you were able to win the trust of the
black cube agents hired by Harvey
Weinstein to stalk and intimidate you
and have to explain what that means the
folks who are black cube is an Israeli
private intelligence firm that touts its
close connections to the Mossad it's run
by a lot of former Mossad and other
Israeli intelligence and military
personnel and they did have a
subcontractor operation where there was
a Russian spy and a Ukrainian spy kind
of chasing me around for a lot of the
plot of catch and kill and look one of
the inspiring things about these events
despite all the darkness in them is time
and time again
there were whistleblowers who saw bad
stuff happening and said enough I'm
going to report it and one of those guys
chasing me becomes a source how do you
know we're not chasing you you know for
a time it's sort of it's paranoia of
seeing the same car over and over again
seeing the same guy over and over again
and then ultimately it is receipts I'm
an attorney and a skeptical
investigative reporter and I get all the
contracts showing exactly how the
operation went and one of these guys at
the heart of it was one of the many
sources who stood up and said I care
about the Free Press I don't want to be
tracking reporters one of the craziest
things in it is you described getting
all these text messages like just dozens
and dozens that I'm like if that is not
a way a method I would have thought to
be spied on but now it's made me
paranoid they use my phone to track me
there's a lot of different methods but
it actually it ties into some very high
stakes issues globally - right because
Jamal khashoggi z-- friends had this
kind of spyware on their phones an
Israeli company called NSO group is one
of the main in person when you want to
get serious with this [ __ ] you get
Israelis you know there when I went to
Europe to tour what four years ago who
protected me Israelis that's who we got
we got [ __ ] Israel there's a lot of
great private firms out of Israel that
do good work on security right now I'm
just saying didn't night was able to
mask all their agents so I don't know if
it's a ringing endorsement okay dr.
Gordon how concerned are you about the
new report that says 95% of baby food
contains toxic metals it does I tell
people to please make their own baby
food I don't trust
the manufacturers of children's products
whether it's pharmaceuticals or baby
food
and I I worry a lot about about the new
vaccine laws which have taken the
decision about vaccines away from
parents initially gave it to me and now
there's going to be a government
committee in California deciding whether
or not you medically qualify for vaccine
exemption and those laws are going to
spread across the United States unless
we slow them down and the Sheep not
applauding okay so Dennis how can you
justify saying truth is not a left-wing
value when Donald Trump has lied over
thirteen thousand times in staking
office he does lie you would agree with
that he does wait wait first of all what
about like when he makes it like you
said he talked to Mitch McConnell and
Mitch McConnell said we never had a
conversation okay does that present live
like that so allow me to explain my
comment okay all right first of all
Donald Trump is Donald Trump Donald
Trump is not right-wing or our concern
Donald Trump is Donald Trump okay the
left-wing on me the left-wing I'll tell
you what at me I'll tell you what it
means it means not the left-wing is
infinitely larger than one person I
don't know who's one left-wing person
who tells a lie the left-wing says I'll
give you gigantic lies that the United
States is a racist country this this is
a lie this isn't a gargantuan lie this
is the least racist multicultural
multi-ethnic country in the history of
the world that these people believe it
is proof to me but about how effective
long ago via Whittaker but this is an
unbelievably non racist country have you
people been to Asia do you people know
that other Japanese did not allow one
Vietnamese boat person into Japan okay
cuz they're not Japanese but we allowed
them into America what is that better
than the Japanese argument is greatest
in any country with many races it is a
lie of course this Rick I'm a Jew okay
our anti-semites in America it is a
giant lie that America is anti-semitic I
taught Jewish history in college I know
what I wrote books on Judaism this is
the least anti-semitic country Jews have
ever lived in to say America's
anti-semitic is a lie to say this racist
is a lie okay these are giant left-wing
law we're talking about degrees say that
men can menstruate is a lie and that is
now that is what it said not menstruate
what's considered transphobic I missed
this whole story just google it can men
menstruate who is saying this you're
saying that how do you allow men the
biological men to run against women in
in the races in Connecticut and set all
the records okay but they're called men
no nation said they're women but I would
agree with you on that the way you
framed it is nonsense we don't like
worried it perfectly I don't know you
didn't what you're talking about is yes
someone who is transgendered was a man
now claims to be a woman there's a woman
okay is beating the dog [ __ ] out of
other women in the race because of
course they have more muscle mass and
even Martina Navratilova came out and
said this is ridiculous
you might know it might as well not have
women's board this is a far cry from
saying men can menstruate okay at the
University of Berkeley men's room
tampons are given out check it out Cal
UC Berkeley men's rooms have tampon
dispensers would you say that because
men are [ __ ] whipped and they're gross
they don't get me a tampon
[Applause]
okay alright moving on to the next in
tennis I remember you in the old show
you were a little more reasonable we
think that no one does you that the
LGBTQ normative statement is Menken
menstruate with north america generating
more talk about another kind of gusher
with north with north america fitting
[Applause]
with north america generating most of
the oil that's used in the united states
why is the u.s. still in the Middle East
now I read this week that we get 16% of
our oil from the Middle East countries
that's not much only thirty billion
dollars do we spend on it most of it we
get from US Canada get half candidate we
get like half and they have zero
warlords and and Mexico why are we why
are we spending
untold billions to protect this area
that we're only spending 30 billion on
oil for it makes no sense
well it should be liberating for us I
mean we we started to get involved in
the in the Middle East in 1945 when we
wanted oil when there was oil discovery
in Saudi Arabia and Iran we are now as
of the last two years the world's
largest energy producer not just oil
itself but all kinds of other forms of
energy and it should liberate us from
having to be there what's ironic and
silly about what Donald Trump has done
is he's taken out a thousand special
operations forces in Syria by the way
the same guys who got al-baghdadi we
have 14,000 people in Kuwait we have
13,000 people in Qatar let's bring some
of them home I agree we should have a
smaller footprint in the in the Middle
East and the person who tried to do that
with Barack Obama there's also reasons
to be present strategically other than
military presence and we've talked about
this before yeah we have strip-mined our
diplomatic apparatus and in a lot of
these countries we now have primarily a
military posture that is completely
needless it costs us in multiple ways
and it's changed the face we put forward
to the world we need any mats in these
places look I think the fact that we had
a small number of troops in Syria but
still American troops all you need is a
couple of thousand and it and this is
why before Trump did his thing three
weeks ago we didn't lose Syria now Iran
has an overland route into Hezbollah I
thought you were a big Israel lover
you're okay with that your boy get Syria
to the Russians and the Iranians and now
Israel is going to have your Iranian
you're right I'm right of us for the
record wait just for the record I want
everyone to know The Wall Street Journal
and every single Republican and
conservative columnist I have read
including people I've had on my show
disagreed with the President on Syria so
just know about the cult issue I don't
know who's in that cult because every
Republican I have read opposed the
President on that issue well I would
advise you to look at Lindsey Graham's
comments on that because at first he
said what you're saying now I don't
agree and then he was like president
thinks out of the box this could work
okay me all right you know this idea
that the president doesn't have enablers
and lackeys right did you read the
comment from his press secretary who
said general Kelly quit because he
couldn't he couldn't take the genius
that is Donald Trump did you see that
okay secretaries it's unfair to pick on
them they they were again aníbal role
did any press secretary ever say that
anything like that okay if that's what
she said it's a silly sheet she did okay
keep talking monkey ourselves I'm gonna
find this card okay
I'll say something we are in the Middle
East not just for oil
wherever American troops are Liberty
expands that look at Korea look at
Germany look at Japan the the if they're
if they gave the Nobel Peace Prize to
those who deserve it the American
military would get it every year here's
the comment she said I worked with John
Kelly and he was totally unequipped to
handle the genius of our great president
you're telling me that sounds like
that's that's what [ __ ] Kim Jong Un's
people to handle the genius or a great
president but we're free to laugh at it
so it's not corn orth Korea is it we're
laughing at the president's press
secretary if you let Kim Jong right
secretary you're dead we're looking at
the trajectory of where we might go
today we're laughing tomorrow who knows
thank you everybody
[Applause]
you